hey y'all it's andrew couch here and in
this tuesday video we're gonna be going
over
dimensionality reduction methods for
machine learning
so with the actual model that i created
in season one
where i was predicting ufc fights uh we
were dealing with a lot of features
specifically we're doing like over 200
features um
additionally with all the features that
i created were
like or moving averages um auto
aggressive features
you know we're combining a fighters
uh data with the opponent's data and
they all shared the same amount of
features
so we can see how you know that in
itself doubles our actual features that
we're utilizing
so one of the questions i actually got
in the video when we're doing a bunch of
feature engineering is
how do i know if a feature you know adds
value to the model i don't know if
the model actually works with these
features and how can we you know reduce
the amount of features we actually use
um especially when we're dealing with
like highly correlated values
so i actually went back and revisited
the actual modeling stand
up the modeling for both the component
models
where we were trying to predict like
strikes landed knockdowns
submission attempts etc i also was
uh created a actual like outcome model
that would predict you know
probability of like a knockout
tko decision etc for both parties
but um for this video i figured we'd
just focus on you know just one model
um in this case i think predicting
strikes landed
uh probably makes the most sense just
because one
um it was one of the more stronger
features into our actual outcome model
i'm in two it's more intuitive and the
actual range of values is pretty large
whereas like knockdowns you know there's
usually only about
zero to five or zero to ten on
knockdowns actually probably not ten
knockdowns but
you get what i'm talking about where you
know there's gonna be way more strikes
landed
um it's way more variable than uh these
other features
so i actually have uh wrote this script
out
um and i don't think the coding part is
really that important
because first of all there really isn't
that much coding uh it's more about you
know just
what commands we can think about using
um in our own problems
so i'm basically loading in some of our
data that we're
going to use to create our model data um
so we have fight data some fights and a
fighter table
i don't use all of it um i think they
probably removed the
match df if i want to think about it but
um right now what we're trying to do is
we have our fighter data frame which
contains you know
each fighters you know basically
features that we've already created so
like the average strikes
um knockdowns received you know their
their um previous history
and um stuff like that um strike um
lag features um we also have like
takedowns
total losses total strikes avoided you
know when
by what type and their elo and then
their eo change from their past
uh uh their past fight
so what we're gonna have to do is one we
want to remove any data leakage so
in this case it has like results from
the actual fights
um the round finished um and that stuff
we don't really want
because it'll kind of uh cause issues
with our actual model
so we're going to remove that um
additionally we're also going to rename
them so we're going to basically take
our our data frame and basically join it
with itself
because each row of the fighter data
frame represents a fighter and if we
actually go back
and look at our uh our fight pk
uh we can see that we have
basically um two fight pks so we would
want to join you know sierra gone with
rows and strike together
right um so i basically did that
um just a basic join um and as you can
see
uh with the actual data i just selected
you know the fight bk which represents
the actual match now
the fighter the opponent um and then
with their um actual fights we can see
it's
flipped too um zero gone is the fighter
and then cirrogun is also the opponent
uh and then we can see just at the sandy
check that you know when zero khan is
the fighter
his average knockdowns is 0.0.5 uh when
sirogon is the opponent we can see the
opponent's average knockdowns
is 0.5 uh so right there we know we have
our data
it's nice and labeled and prepped for
what we want uh we also have this little
target strike landed which
is the thing that we're trying to
predict okay
so if we're actually looking at this we
have two fights and they're essentially
the same fight
um they're kind of switched around uh so
in this case
uh i wanted to basically group by each
fight bk
and just sample one little um one
fighter's perspective from each fight
um i definitely think you could probably
leave this as is
uh but just you know just make sure
nothing crazy is going on
we're going to switch it around so just
from a baseline we can check our
model data columns which is about 282
features
and that's a lot of features uh you know
if i was using linear regression
there's no way i would use a linear
regression model because you know one
we're dealing with a lot of correlated
features
two our actual amount of parameters
we're gonna be estimating
is definitely likely to overfit so
how can we actually you know reduce the
amount of features that we have
uh to make sure that uh you know we're
making an efficient model
um i'm not gonna go into
like all the actual feature engineering
that i created so i did i did a lot of
like fighter
um head-to-head features such as like
you know whether they're
um the ego scores are greater or lower
you know the ego differentials i also
created some striking
metrics and some uh um strike
differential metrics and stuff like that
um i don't think that's too important
for this um
uh this video so i'm just gonna leave it
as is and just kind of
go as like a brute force approach where
we're just gonna have
uh the the the default you know ufc data
without any actual intuition
or knowledge behind um the actual sports
itself which is probably not the best
idea
uh when you're done when you're doing a
side project um it's generally good to
put in your own
um prior knowledge and your own
intuition to it but for this video just
to make it um
more accessible for non-mma fans where
it's going to go as is
so when we're dealing with um
oops when we're dealing with these
these uh this data we want to do a few
pre-processing
so one of the preprocessing that we've
added was the
dummy to all the categorical variables
in this case if we actually look at the
prep
option uh we can see that we're just
applying the dumb variables to the
weight glass
and that's fine so it's just um i know i
did a one-hot encoding just because i
prefer one-hot encoded
uh features but you know you can always
do a dummy if you want
but for the models that we're going to
be using uh i think one hot encoding
makes the most amount of sense
so um if we check our columns we have
um 293 columns that is a lot of columns
and we need to figure out you know what
can we do to
reduce that you know just even uh before
we even start modeling it we know that
that's a lot of features
um and it might and probably nine times
out of ten we know we don't need this
many features
okay so for the basic dimensionality
reduction we can kind of just do what we
already know about so one we obviously
add that mean imputation because we can
see that
you know the average reversals and half
the missing values
and that's a problem with my scraping
script um generally these na should be
zero but i know with the average
reversals i'm fine with just imputing
uh the mean i could also do median if i
want to
but that's not really going to do
anything crazy um
one thing that i will say is we should
also pretty much always include
a step near zero variance um this will
remove like any columns where
you know all the samples kind of share
the same value
um so i did near zero variance also try
to remove any linear combinations
um just to see if that will remove some
of the columns
and then also did apply the generic
dummy um
features so we're just still going to do
the dummy on the weight class
and as you can see we have we went from
293 columns to 198
which is actually pretty good you know
um managed to remove like almost 100
features
i'm just uh right out of the pack so
this right here is something that you
know
is is pretty useful when we can just
remove redundant stuff
um and it's something you know if we
don't have a lot of features maybe
consider not doing it but
if we do have a lot of features it's
generally pretty easy and pretty free
um for our resource standpoint to just
do the near zero variance winner
combinations
uh to remove any um columns that we
think that the model wouldn't really
get any information of another thing
that we
also can include is step core
or correlation and we're basically
removing any highly correlated features
um one thing i also could say with the
step correlation is that i think the
default is
like 70 70 or it's 90. we can remove we
can change that threshold
with a simple tune so if i wanted to do
um
a threshold and i can say tune and i can
say like
um core tune right and then we can throw
it
into our grid and then we can tune in
based off that which it
you know which would add a little bit
more granularity into our actual models
so we can figure out you know what we
want to actually remove
so with the actual correlation filter
um we managed to remove even more
features right so 136 or 198 minus 136
just because i don't feel like doing
math
is 62. so we additionally removed
another 62 features
um and we were able from comparing our
baseline with no
feature dimensional reduction we've you
know we've removed over 100 features
which is always really good but if we
think about it
um a lot of our features should be kind
of correlated together right
we're using these moving averages which
should be kind of related towards our
other ar
um our other moving average features so
we have like a weighted moving average
a moving average that uses two of them
uh two of the previous fights and moving
average that used three of the previous
fights
like a moving average that uses all the
previous fights so we can see that those
variables should be pretty correlated
together
um so what i actually want to do is kind
of look at these correlate features
and just figure out like which values
are just like the most correlated
so right here um twill takedowns
absorbed and total knockdowns absorbed
um are highly correlated right they're
one to one
and we kind of know that because if you
get knocked down or if you get a
takedown
it could be a knock down too um same
with like total strikes a fighter swirl
strikes avoided
uh and a buyer's total significance rex
avoided we know that strikes and
significant
strikes are basically one to one
correlated because
if you throw a significant strike it is
still counted as a strike
um and that's something where you know
maybe we don't want to remove
those features because we know that
total strike since total signal strikes
are a little bit different and we may
want to just prioritize
total significance strikes instead of
total strikes
right um so we can kind of see here that
again
most of our correlated values are pretty
high
uh right um so it removes a lot of it
um what i also want to do is kind of
just plot out a histogram of
on the actual correlated values for all
the features i also will say that
um i did a little filter just so we can
remove any redundancies so like
uh pairwise flip um pairwise features
so it kind of just keeps the first you
know subset
or first light combination um so you see
you know i have pretty long tails
towards the upper ends where it's or i'm
sure that the corollary features
um filter just kind of little did a
little cut right there and said we're
removing all that garbage
okay so one other concept too that i
think is pretty popular
is like just use a pca um principle
components analysis
um and that can basically turn
all these correlate features into these
components and then we can use our model
to just
you know keep on chugging um pca linear
regression i think is pretty popular
um i will say i think max kuhn says that
he doesn't really get a lot of value
from it
probably because i think he comes from
like a pharmaceutical background
uh where all these like correlate
structures are probably important
but i am definitely not in uh chemistry
i'm not chemist or in
big pharma so i definitely don't know
but i'm sure
he has his reasons why but what's cool
about step pca
is that we can kind of change a
threshold or we can specify specific
components so
we can kind of manually determine one
the actual amount of features we want to
use
or we can have some type of rule-based
um
role-based system where we can say we
want to explain we want the components
explained at least like 75 percent of
the variance
or maybe if we can increase it knowing
uh
that that'll also be related towards the
number of components created
right so if 0.75 if we just say 0.9
um see we we we basically
double we we more than double our our
features
but it's still 60 which is better than
the rest of our
actual pre-processing methods so
one other way to actually address high
dimensional
correlated structures is just use a
model that can kind of handle that
um and for me when i think of like high
dimensional
data uh i definitely think about you
know like
a tree based model so you can just use
your simple decision tree from our part
you know just tune the tree depth make
sure that we don't have too deep
of a tree uh also make sure that we have
a decent amount of samples in each
little node and we also can tune our
cost complexity too
right so i generally will never use a
simple decision tree
uh maybe if i'm doing an ensemble or
stacking of a bunch of machine learning
models but
in real life decision trees or the basic
are part decision tree is not very
useful
from a pure predictive standpoint um i
think there's a common phrase where you
know the only problem with decision
trees is that
you're not good at predicting things and
i think that's pretty true
you know that's why we have these
ensemble methods like random forest and
xg boost
so again um with these tree based models
uh obviously like for me i'm always
using random force or actually boost
models
i definitely use way more random force
models in my own work
but actually these models are totally
fine and for some reason i do have like
an inclination to use xgb's models with
with regression problems
but i don't think actually actually
boost is like specifically better in
regression
versus classification problems compared
to random force uh
i think just in my limited work uh that
i've noticed i've i've just
uh leaned towards random forest um one
of the main reasons why
i actually cater towards more of a
random force model
is even though they have similar
performance and i think realistically
actually boost model
will have a slightly a slight edge in
in some cases especially with these like
analyses or postdocs of
machine learning competitions but one of
the reasons why like random forest model
uh framework the best or the random
forest algorithm is that we have way
less parameters to tune
you know we just have min and uh number
of features that are samples and the
number of trees
whereas with xg boost we have you know
trees number trees
tree depth um you know learning rates
uh stuff iterations uh all that stuff
which can be very useful especially with
the stop iterations but for me
you know let's keep it simple just tune
two of these um
parameters that's available we know that
m tree is basically
uses the square root of the amount of
features available i think
um so that's kind of our that's like the
basic rule i believe so
we only have like two parameters of two
inverses we're actually boost you know
there's way more parameters to tune uh
which can cause a lot of issues
so once we have a tree based model um
i think if you don't want to use a tree
based model you want to use like you
know like a canyons neighbor model
or um you know linear regression we can
actually do like
a basic manual inspection using very
very variable importance um
right now i just created a random forest
model with 500 trees baseline parameters
but we can also set the importance to
impurity and we just fit into our train
data
and using the vip package we can get a
little nice
plot of what the model sees as the
um very important features that are used
for predicting things and we can kind of
see that
yeah if we're trying to predict strikes
landed the fighter sig rag mixture is
basically like the proportion of
significant strikes to strikes so they
have a hyper uh
mixture of uh significant strikes i'm
sure it has a nice predictive capability
to predict strikes landed right so we
can see it you know it's using a bunch
of strikes same as strike
metrics it's also using the opponent's
signal strikes and strikes metrics
um it's also looking at the takedown
percent so you know for me just
for me thinking about it like maybe if
they have a lower or higher t
you know maybe if they can threaten the
takedown more than more often just
um keep it standing up and just fighting
which will lead to
a higher strikes landed and then finally
we can see that elo
or you know our elo score um
plays some importance and that's pretty
good because if we think about it you
know if a fighter has a high evo
or has beaten beaten a lot a lot of very
good fighters they're probably pretty
good at striking um generally
yeah generally you know champions are
pretty good at striking
so that's something again that would
expect and if you know
a lot about mma or you just kind of know
a little bit about mma and you can use
some of these features you kind of like
intuitively determine like
okay we don't really need those arma
features we kind of just
care more about these mixtures and
percentages you know
we know that take we finally know that
like oh it actually take down
i was pretty useful so maybe we can go
back maybe do some take down
um we can create some take down features
and re-run this thing
and just see what it's also trying this
uh trying to do
again i definitely would try to avoid
like data leakage so
try to keep it on the trained data and
stuff like that in this case we're just
you know juicing our train data using
our baseline recipe
okay and finally what we can do is we
can kind of do the brute force approach
um which is recursive feature
elimination where it basically
goes through and iterates and you know
chooses what features to use
takes them out and then we can assess
really what the model sees
um that deems a important feature so
we're kind of using a model
to basically select the features for us
um
one obviously this is very great because
you know we can kind of have a more
systematic
approach to it that also has more of a
structure to it instead of using our own
intuition you know there's more of a
science than an art
but one of the main issues with
recursive future elimination
is it really is like the brute force
approach to
uh dimensionality reduction where you
know we can
uh it's gonna take a lot longer
and additionally you know it could cause
a lot of overfitting or it could just
choose some features that
you know maybe uh it didn't make any
sense it just uh
just so happens to be uh having a strong
relationship
to our target variable so what we're
going to do though
is we're going to just define our
baseline model which will be
uh which will be like selecting our
features
and then we can create our basic recipe
and then we can add our step
select vip so instead of us kind of
going through the vip plots and looking
at
you know the variable importance and
just filtering by like zero and just
kind of reading it
um we're going to have the model base
kind of go through it and do it itself
and then we can set our own threshold by
doing some tune function
so we're actually going to run this and
we're going to apply the recipe
uh to it which is going to actually
remove all the features that we that the
model sees is not useful
and now we can kind of compare it once
it runs to
what our manual inspection with our
variable importance versus this one
i will also say that we use different
importance um
rules so in instead of permutation we
used
um impurity so that's another thing that
we can consider is you know what type of
importance we
should use for our variable importance
measurements so we're going to let it go
and and see again right now it's taking
a decent amount of time to actually
um run the recursive feature engineering
our future elimination
but um it is pretty useful i'm actually
while we're gonna wait for this to load
i'm gonna go through the actual recipe
selectors package
um it's still in development so you have
to do like an install github
but it's very useful especially since
it's adding a lot of the
feature elimination methods from carrot
and i've only gone through the step vip
but there's also like
step slot cross tab there's an roc
um there's maximum relevancy minimum
redundancy feature selection
there's info gain so there's a bunch of
other methods that we can do
um in this case you know i'm not really
familiar with all these things i
i'm feeling with like roc crosstab and
vip but
and i guess information game but like
step mlr mr
uh beruta and kara score is something
that uh
uh i'm not very familiar with but you
know it's something they also consider
to use
okay so if we actually look at this
compared to our
our filtered vi variable importance
where we say
anything that's above zero or not
important uh we'll
include we can see that we have 26
features
versus essentially 30 features because
it's still going to include the uh
the the outcome variable but you can see
what it's saying is like
you know again sigma strikes you know
this strike mixture
is pretty useful for our model but we
also notice that
you know it's also including eo and
opponent stuff but it's not
including as much opponent data right
than we would expect so it's like total
strikes absorb
total strikes avoided um received so
it's kind of measuring like you know a a
person or a fighter is
a strike metrics with the opponent's
defensive and offensive strikes
metrics so as you can see it's a very
useful thing it's pretty very strong
but we know that you know we're missing
um
uh where it's adding a few things that
you know maybe we think it might be
redundant etc
um so that's basically it for this video
i know this again this is a pretty quick
video i actually recorded
um i'm recording this video right after
my um starting video on docker
on back to back just because i i uh i
have some free time this weekend to work
on it so
i figured i'd record back-to-back just
to you know free up some time but
honestly i think these methods right
here are
some very good starting grounds um for
what you want to do
um when dealing with the high
dimensional features um i haven't gone
over like dealing with high like
categorical features with a large amount
of levels
and not use utilizing embedding and
stuff like that but i think that'll be
for
a future video especially for like text
analysis
so uh with that being said um i hope you
guys enjoyed the video
and i'll see you guys next time and uh
teddy on